>> IS A GOOD QUESTION, NUMBER
ONE, I WAS A DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
EVER BEEN TO A CAUCUS?
NO, YOU HAVE BEEN.
HE WERE A LYING DOG FACED NOW
YOU HAVE TO BE HONEST AND I’M
GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: THERE HE IS
BREATHING HEAVILY INTO THE
MICROPHONE, THE MAN, THE
GENIUSES IN WASHINGTON PICKED IT
PROTECT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FROM THE GREAT SOCIALIST THREAT
AND BABBLING ABOUT JOHN WAYNE
MOVIES THAT DON’T EXIST PUTTING
ALL THEIR HOPES INTO TWO TINY
MAYORS PROPPED UP BY IMMENSE
PILES OF CASH.
IS A HILARIOUS IF NOTHING ELSE.
JOINING US NOW TO MAKE SENSE OF
IT IS MARK STEYN, WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON’T THINK
IT IS A JOHN WAYNE MOVIE.
I THINK HE IS REFERRING TO A
MOVIE CALLED PONY SOLDIER IN
WHICH TYRONE POWER PLAYED A
MOUNTIE COP IN CANADA.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> SO I DON’T KNOW WHETHER HE
JUST GOT CONFUSED THERE.
WE CALL ON THE DEMOCRATS, WE
LOOK TO THEM TO SPEAK TRUTH TO
POWER, JOE BIDEN WAS SPEAKING
TRUTH TO TYRONE POWER.
JOE BIDEN WAS HAD HIS STRONGEST
THAT THEY ANNOUNCED THAT ITS ALL
BEEN DOWNHILL AND IT IS SAD TO
SEE THAT PITIFUL GROUP OF MY
FELLOW GRANITE STATORS SINGING
AND JOE BIDEN’S BACK.
I’VE GOT NO PROBLEMS WITH
JOE BIDEN’S BACK.
THE PROBLEM IS JOE BIDEN’S
FRIEND.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIM, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HIS FACE, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT HIS MOUTH, IT IS CLEAR HIS
HEART ISN’T IN THIS AND THAT WAS
OBVIOUS, YOU CAN’T HAVE LEGACY
CANDIDATES.
THEY TRIED THAT FOUR YEARS AGO
AND NOW THEY ARE STUCK IN THE
WORST OF ALL WORLDS.
THEY NEED SOMEONE.
THEY RICO, JOE BIDEN’S BACK.
IF YOU WANT A GOOD BACK SONG, MY
BOYFRIEND’S BACK BY THE ANGELS.
BUT NUMBER 37 IN 1961, THAT’S
THE ONE, FORGET JOE BIDEN’S
BACK.
NOW I AM ALL DISTRACTED.
I DON’T WANT TO THINK ABOUT
JOE BIDEN’S BACK.
THEY’VE GOT THE SAME PROBLEM
THAT THE REPUBLICANS HAD FOUR
YEARS AGO.
WHO CAN TAKE OUT BERNIE AND NONE
OF THESE GUYS CAN TAKE OUT
BERNIE AND MY ONLY DISAGREEMENT
WITH WHAT YOU SAID WAS WHEN YOU
MENTIONED AMY KLOBUCHAR AND WE
ALL DISMISS HER AS THE SENSIBLE
SHOES CANDIDATE AND ALL THE REST
OF IT BUT ON THAT STAGE WHEN
THEY WERE ASKED WHICH OF THEM
WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH A
SOCIALIST CANDIDATE, IN OTHER
WORDS ACTUALLY BEING ASKED WHICH
OF YOU GUYS IS READY TO TAKE OUT
BERNIE, THE ONLY ONE WHO SAID
SHE DIDN’T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE SOCIALIST CANDLE THAT WAS
AMY KLOBUCHAR.
AND I GENERALLY TAKE THE VIEW
THAT WHO DARES WINS HERE AND SHE
WAS THE ONLY ONE ON THAT STAGE
TO ACTUALLY SHOW ANY COURAGE.
>> Tucker: IS IN IT TIME, THEY
WERE REFLEXES AND THAT’S A VERY
SMART POINT.
THEIR REFLEX IS TO GO RIGHT TO
THE BILLIONAIRE.
THEY’VE GOT A PROBLEM AND THE
BILLIONAIRE IS GOING TO SAVE
THEM FROM THE PROBLEM AND WHAT
DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT THEM?
>> I THINK THEY ARE DIFFERENT
FROM THE REPUBLICANS, BUT THE
REPUBLICANS WANTED TO GET RID OF
TRUMP AND COULDN’T FIND A WAY TO
DO SO HONESTLY.
RIGHT NOW ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
WE ARE HAVING CEREAL MALODOROUS
MALODOROUSNESS STARTING FROM THE
IOWA POLL THAT WASN’T RELEASED,
THEN THE IOWA CAUCUS, NOW
WHOEVER WINS THAT, WHOEVER WINS
NEW HAMPSHIRE WILL GIVE THEM A
LOT OF MOMENTUM GOING INTO THE
IOWA CAUCUS RESULTS WHICH MIGHT
WELL BE RE-CAUCUSED.
SO THEY INTERFERED IN THAT, NOW
THEY’RE TRYING TO INTERFERE BY
BRINGING BACK SUPERDELEGATES, BY
PUTTING THE BILLIONAIRE ON THE
STAGE, ALL OF THESE ARE STICKS
OF DYNAMITE THAT THE
YOSEMITE SAM’S OF THE DEMOCRATS
FROM THE MEDIA KEEP SHOVING DOWN
THEIR PARENTS.
AND EACH ONE OF THEM SO FAR
STARTING WITH IMPEACHMENT IS
ACTUALLY BLOWN UP IN THEIR FACES
AND THEY STILL KEEP SHUFFLING
THE DYNAMITE DOWN THEIR PANTS.
>> Tucker: IT JUST COULDN’T
HAPPEN TO BETTER PEOPLE.
IT’S HARD TO WATCH, MAD MY DAY